cbs news has learned that there has been
at least
one face-to-face meeting presumptive
democratic presidential nominee joe
biden has had
as he prepares to name his running mate
michigan governor gretchen whitmer
traveled by
private plane from michigan to delaware
sunday evening to meet with biden and to
discuss being his number two
as ed o'keefe reports the revelation
comes as the hours
tick away closer to a formal
announcement
joe biden stayed close to his delaware
home friday as his team remains
tight-lipped about who he might choose
as a running mate
a formal announcement is expected next
week meanwhile president trump who
trails biden in polls is lashing out at
his rival
this time it was comments the former
vice president made about african
americans
biden had to clarify comments made in an
interview about immigration
unlike the african-american community
with notable exceptions
the latino community is an incredibly
diverse community
with incredibly different attitudes
about different things
you go to florida you find a very
different attitude about immigration
in certain places than you do when
you're in arizona it was a very
insulting statement he made
late thursday biden tweeted in no way
did i mean to suggest the
african-american community is a monolith
not by identity not on issues not at all
of course mr trump has his own long
history of racially insensitive remarks
about minorities and immigrants
and on thursday he also took on biden's
faith he's following
the radical left agenda take away your
guns
destroy your second amendment no
religion know anything
hurt the bible hurt god he's against god
biden a catholic called mr trump's
comments shameful
and beneath the office he holds looking
ahead to the political conventions
democrats say that their four night all
virtual gathering will include speeches
by party leaders and regular americans
affected by the pandemic
or the economic downturn as the party
puts it
viewers can expect quote fewer people
behind podiums
and more people in living rooms for cbs
this morning saturday
ed o'keefe washington